Like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for you no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counsel three two one
action
I've been making this directing journey for a
decade right to enter into this level of fan-based
really adored franchise world it's a big
responsibility welcome back eddie brock
i miss you so much it very much felt it was in
my wheelhouse creating characters using cg is
obviously something that i've been involved
with for the last two decades now
i've spent a considerable amount of my life
playing a character with two sides to its
personality and there's common ground
there we had a deal what's gonna happen
you're gonna stop protecting me i am happy to
eat mrs chet no no you cannot eat mrs chen what
nothing the digital characters have got to
seriously act they've got to be totally believable
i wanted to find a physical
vocabulary for carnage that was
entirely different to venom everything was
always underpinned by reality and a truth
i think it's the perfect movie in a way because
it's very celebratory of what cinema can do
Welcome back everyone this is my new venom
let there be carnage video they dropped some
new footage and andy circus talking about
the movie there's a couple of minor easter
eggs here in spider-man references people were
asking about that i'll explain and they kind of
backdoor confirmed tom hardy's venom showing up
inside the morbius movie in a slightly different
way if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i know everyone's
asking about the spiderman no way home trailer
there's all these rumors i'll address that at
the end of the video too we are entering prime
spider-man season between venomotherby carnage
spider-man no way home then we have the morbius
movie coming in january and then spider-man into
the spider-verse 2 also coming out next year the
even bigger stanley easter egg that they confirm
here also a big spider-man a big venom easter
egg so obviously this cover is commemorating
the amazing quote-unquote life of stan lee amazing
spider-man reference the 86 is a reference to 1986
in web of spider-man number 16 when they teased
the existence of eddie brock's venom character in
the comics he only saw eddie brock's hand but they
were just teasing him showing up in the comics and
becoming the venom character eventually the first
actual full venom appearance didn't happen until
1988 in amazing spider-man number 300. but
we get a little bit of new footage with andy
circus talking about venom let there be carnage
talking about entering the spider-man franchise
that already has a very very large fan base and
likening that to the same responsibility that
they all felt working on the lord of the rings
movies in the hobbit movies and how he spent the
last 20 years of his life working on characters
using the same techniques that they used on venom
lithium carnage to create the symbiotes with a
combination of motion capture and special effects
although if you watch the behind the scenes on the
original lord of the rings movies from 20 years
ago and you see him doing his motion capture
reference for a gollum crawling around it was
way way more primitive at the time and way harder
for him to do he talks all the time about how it
wrecked his body and wrecked his voice to do the
gollum voice while he was crawling around on his
hands and knees and they filmed all three of those
original lord of the rings movies back to back
when he compares the golem character being
similar to venom in the carnage symbiotes
because they all have multiple personalities
during the movie he's mostly talking about eddie
and the venom symbiote at the beginning of the
film because their relationship has deteriorated
it feels very much like a dual personality
because they want completely separate things
as we saw in the last big trailer the venom
symbiote is fighting him it says it's born to
be a predator it wants to do what it was meant
to do go around eating people and not giving an
f about humans being pure id just giving in to
all its base or animal instincts just doing the
first thing that pops into its head in any given
moment in eddie's trying to live this relatively
normal life he's working for the daily bugle they
actually recently confirmed j jonah jameson would
appear in the movie we all expected him to show up
at some point so it's not quite as big a surprise
clearly he's writing this article about
cletus kasady who's trying to sort of
draw him in because cletus is obsessed with eddie
keeps sending him these notes written in his own
blood the whole idea with that is that there's
all these people that he killed in bodies that
they never found so that's how he tempts eddie
into coming to write this article about him
the whole thing with patrick mulligan during
the trailer because he does eventually become
the toxin character in the comics the toxin
symbiote is the offspring of the carnage symbiote
maybe eventually they'll work up to that in the
venom sequels it sounds like they want to do as
many different symbiotes as they can but because
he gets so pissed off during the trailer reading
all these articles that eddie brock is writing
about cletus kasady it sounds like he was the
detective that originally put cletus kasady
in prison and now learning that there are all
these bodies that are hidden all over the place
that they never found the police never found it
makes him look really bad but as eddie says in
the trailer and he even puts that sign up in his
apartment no eating people he doesn't want to do
anything that the symbiote wants to do so he has
to kind of fight the symbiote for control of their
shared body so to speak at least early in the film
it doesn't seem like it's till carnage bonds with
cletus kasady and then they escape prison free
his girlfriend shriek from ravencroft all the way
on the other side of the country in new york city
then they threaten anne wang the love of eddie's
life like his version of a mary jane watson
character that they both then get back on the
same page and work together in true symbiosis
like he says during the trailer i will let you
eat everybody the whole concept of the symbiotes
is that when the symbiote is in sync with its
host body perfectsync the more powerful they
can become which is why cletus kasady is so much
more powerful than venom at first when he gets
the carnage symbiote as we see a version of the
carnage symbiote's origin story playing out in
this trailer here like he bites eddie and it seems
like eddie's blood which is tainted with the venom
symbiote mixes with cletus kasady's blood creating
the carnage symbiote so the carnage symbiote is
meant to be an offspring of the venom symbiote
but they're kind of explaining him getting the
carnage symbiote in a slightly different way than
he did in the comics but the whole idea that the
symbiote wants to act on pure impulse become utter
chaos and cletus kasady represents that he wants
utter chaos as he mentions a couple times in the
trailer so they are fully in sync with each other
when they bond making them crazy op all while
eddie is still fighting the venom symbiote for
control hamstringing them early on the other big
spider-man easter egg that a lot of people spotted
during this and were kind of confused by is that
they feature a piece of concept art in the title
of the concept art the name of the file is venom
versus spider-man so people are like wait a minute
wait wait a minute it's a spider-man does that
mean that spider-man is somewhere in this movie
but what's actually going on here and this sort
of corroborates what the sony president said about
the movie earlier referencing spider-man and how
he sort of figures into the grand scheme of things
and what tom hardy has said about spider-man
what andy circus has said about spider-man
and the trailer because there are other big
spider-man easter eggs like the daily bugle logo
is from the tobey maguire spider-man movies and
there are several points in the trailer where you
see spiders specifically referenced but what's
actually going on here if you actually read the
file name it says george evangelista venom versus
spiderman this is actually based on concept art
that a fan did a while ago that a concept artist
just did on his own before the movie ever came out
and it sounds like what may have happened is that
he himself like the concept artist got to work on
venom let there be carnage and was using some of
his earlier concept art as a reference for this
so it doesn't mean that spider-man is
going to fight venom during the movie
it's just concept art that he did a long time
ago and that's just what he named that file
they're using concept art for a reference in a
slightly different way in a different context
because it's venom versus carnage instead of venom
versus spider-man but what the sony president has
said though is that the movie is supposed to be
so good that you don't miss spider-man as in he's
probably not going to appear in the movie with
the exception maybe they just reference a lot of
spider-man easter eggs like in the background but
tom holland himself probably isn't going to show
up as peter parker or spider-man other than maybe
sort of a post-credit scene reference of the idea
that eventually there's this multiverse out there
and eventually they'll cross over the way the sony
president talked about it he said that spider-man
no way home is the movie that's going to explain
how the larger spider-man spider verse is going
to work with all these crossovers between marvel
and sony and as implied by the loki finale it'll
be trading on a lot of multiverse tropes with
kang and the multiverse war just opening the idea
that it's much easier for them to just say that
these are happening in alternate universes in
a lot of the mechanics of how they make it from
one universe to another how they travel between
universes will be explained through the events
of spiderman no way home because we have all those
villains from the other spider-man movies we have
doctor octopus from the toby maguire spider-man
movies we have electro from the amazing spider-man
movies and the implied cameos that everyone thinks
we're going to get from toby maguire spider-man
himself and andrew garfield spider-man if you want
to talk about deep cut easter eggs so everybody's
wondering if they're ever going to get up to knoll
the god of the symbiotes inside these venom movies
in the sony universe i think they would love to
do something like that that would be like their
version of avengers end game but marvel just
released their eternals trailer we saw more of
the celestials and we saw a version of jemiah the
analyzer there's actually a theory in the comics
that it is actually nowhere the head of the dead
celestial that was actually killed by null god of
the symbiotes so even though they're not going to
do this in the movies any time soon it is a cool
connection between all these different things
that are happening in these different movies
the first venom movie in a lot of venom leathery
carnage takes place in the san francisco area
where the ant-man movies take place where ant-man
3 quantomania is going to take place and where a
big chunk of the shang shi and the legend of the
ten rings movie takes place for now at least the
movie is still coming out in the middle of october
hopefully that date sticks and supposedly sony is
doing a big three-hour presentation at cinemacon
this next week on monday where they're gonna show
off footage from a bunch of their upcoming
movies including venomous carnage and some
spiderman no way home footage so if you do get
that footage monday or tuesday of course i'll do
all kinds of videos about it everyone click here
for my brand new eternals trailer video in easter
eggs and click here to learn how the eternals
movie is setting up x-men and mutants inside
the mcu thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!